none of the tones were booby traps there
were false doors to some tombs a
corridor designed to lead a potential
Thief to a dead end I'm Anthony Browder
author of now Valley contributions to
civilization and director of the ASA
restoration project currently Excavating
and restoring three cushite tombs today
we're going to be looking at ancient
Egyptian history and film and
determining how real they are
foreign
the top of a sarcophagus that size would
have weighed more than an automobile all
of the sakapha guy that I've seen in
Egypt Were Made of Stone if you can
imagine trying to push an automobile
with two hands it would have been
impossible the thieves who broke into
tombs such as these they were typically
several men and they used heavy duty
instruments
where's your shopping oh well
there would be jewelry on the mummy as
we saw in this instance you would find
that there were little caps that were
put on their fingers
they referenced this property Swati are
small figurines of The Departed soul
that were supposedly built to assist the
dead in the afterlife swapdis were never
put inside of the bodies of a mummy they
were typically buried around them
outside of the sarcophagus and in some
instances there were boxes that
contained swap these the idea of someone
going into a tomb and desecrating a tomb
as this character does is quite
troubling these are historical artifacts
that are Priceless there are hundreds of
tombs in Egypt that have been raided
similar to this it's been happening for
thousands of years I would rate it zero
for historical accuracy
[Music]
one of the things that I liked about
this particular film if you were to walk
into a well-preserved tomb the colors
would be as vibrant today as they were
when the tune was created 3000 years ago
one of the most spectacular tombs in
Egypt in the Valley of the Kings is a
tomb of seti the first and the colors
are so rich so vibrant it looks as if it
was just painted recently the images on
the wall of a priest coming before
Osiris that is an image that comes from
the Papyrus of whomever so this is an
accurate depiction of a 19th Dynasty
personality it is a depiction that comes
straight from his Papyrus and so I
appreciate the attention to detail
[Music]
these glyphs depicted in this scene are
not accurate glyphs the one symbol that
is accurate is the wavy line and then
that's an easy glyph to replicate it's
gibberish but it looks good it helps to
sell the movie
I'm not aware of any of the ancient
Egyptians using a quartz crystal if you
will to illuminate a specific portion of
a temple or a tomb but what we do know
is that there were a number of temples
in ancient Egypt which were oriented to
the Sun for example at Karnak Temple
there is an event that takes place every
winter at the winter solstice a beam of
sunlight shines down the eastern part of
the temple and it would illuminate this
room with a ray of light similar to what
you see here in the film I would give it
a 10 for production value the set
designer gets a lot of credit for doing
their research
what you saw in this battle scene where
what I considered to be fairly accurate
representations of the Chariots of the
armor and the weapons that were used by
the ancient Egyptians and their enemies
there was a chariot buried in King
Touchstone and King Tut lived about a
hundred years before Ramesses who we see
in this particular scene
foreign
there are many texts in Egypt that
describe battles such as this the most
famous archers in the Egyptian Army were
the Nubians they were considered the
best archers in the Nile Valley
typically one would find on the outer
pylon of temples images of the king in a
chariot going into battle to defend
Egypt against the enemies of Egypt this
was I guess Royal propaganda to show
that the King was the protector of the
land Ridley Scott directed this
particular film he gives great attention
to detail I give him a 10 on this
depiction
these home of immortan
Pharaoh's high priest Keeper of the Dead
actually Imhotep was a third Dynasty
priest to the King Zoser then Sakara
which is in Northern Egypt and hotep was
the historical personality who was
responsible for creating the step
pyramid of Sakara Imhotep is also
considered to be the world's first
multi-genius he was a physician deified
by the Greeks he also was an architect
and an engineer
birthplace of anaksuna moon Pharaoh's
mistress
the reference to aksanaman as the
Mistress of seti the first is an extreme
case of someone taking Liberty with the
truth angsten amen was actually the wife
of King Tut who was a 18th Dynasty
personality and Sethi the first was the
19th Dynasty personality so these two
historical figures and they are real
historical figures but they lived about
a century apart from each other so I
have no knowledge of seti the first
having a mistress by the name of oxen
amen
[Music]
foreign
he is depicted in this film as having
murdered the king there is no historical
evidence of Imhotep murdering the king
the representation of impotep and the
other priests as being clean shaven was
accurate typically every priest in Egypt
was clean shaven it was an act of
cleanliness and it was Act of respect
for the positions that they held within
each Temple
had been sent to the dark underworld her
vital organs removed and placed in five
sacred canopic jars they made reference
to her organs were placed in five
canopic jars where anyone who knows
anything about ancient Egyptian history
knows that there are only four canopic
jars the stomach the lungs and some of
the other organs the removal of the
organs was to keep the body clean
the worst of all ancient purses one so
horrible it had never before been
bestowed the reference to impotep's
tongue being cut out to my knowledge
that was not done
priests were condemned to be mummified
alive I'm not aware of any person being
mummified alive mummification was a very
time consuming and expensive process so
there's no reason why a person in the
past would have been buried alive and
the process of mummification in ancient
Egypt typically took place over the
course of 70 days
foreign
the idea of booby traps in ancient
Egyptian tombs is something that comes
from the imagination of film writers
none of the tones were booby traps there
were false doors to some tombs a
corridor designed to lead a potential
Thief to a dead end there were false
corridors and there were shafts to
prevent thieves from coming in to access
the treasure that was buried in a tomb
but there were no booby drops that I'm
aware of I would give it a minus one it
is Holy historically inaccurate
stand up
as they're moving this very heavy statue
they're asking the woman to pour grease
underneath the statue no one knows what
methods they actually use to move these
heavy objects and people take Liberties
at guessing how it was done now there is
a famous image in Egypt where men are
moving a statue and you see a person
standing on top of the statue and
pouring a liquid in front of the statue
implying that this liquid is being used
to ease the movement of this statue
across the sand
oh come here not for myself Lord Prince
for a slave it's an issue that's been
debated for centuries but there is no
evidence whatsoever of slaves having
built the pyramids first and foremost
there are 118 pyramids in Egypt and more
specifically when people speak of
pyramids they're thinking of the three
Great Pyramids of Giza the pyramids of
Khufu kafra and menkara those pyramids
were all built during the fourth Dynasty
which is around 2400 BC that's at least
1200 years before the story of Moses
took place in recent years Egyptian
archaeologists have actually found the
tombs of the Builders of the pyramids
adjacent to the Giza Plateau that honor
would not have been given to a slave we
know that it was built by Master
craftsmen's Master Masons Master
engineers
woman alive in a tomb of Rock
and there's also one other misnomer that
I think is important to talk about the
pyramids were not used as tombs pyramids
were built over tombs I would rate the
depiction of the movement of large box
of stone as accurate the idea of someone
putting grease underneath a block to
help ease this movement across the sand
that's not accurate at all
thank you
foreign
this story depicts the battle between
Horus and set and it is the second part
of the story of the founding of Egypt
this is a story that is over 6 000 years
old in this particular instance the
animal depiction of set is not a jackal
it's an unidentified animal a jackal was
associated with Anubis who was the
guardian of the dead he was the person
who led the souls into the Afterlife the
depiction of Horus as a falcon had to do
with the symbolism associated with the
Falcon the Falcon has Keen eyesight
during Egypt a favor you're not fit to
be king
no they were not British white guys in
Egypt when this picture came out there
was a great deal of controversy because
there's been a great deal of contention
over the last 100 years or so as to the
race of the Egyptians and a lot of it
unfortunately has to do with racism
because many of the early founders of
egyptology happened to be white men who
believed that black people were
inherently inferior to White the
original name
for Egypt was Kemet Kemet is a word
which means the land of the blacks
history has been used as a tool to
subjugate people and to create false
Notions of superiority and inferiority I
only need the answer to the riddle of
the Sphinx a child could deduce while
you're here Toth the god of wisdom
science astronomy and knowledge who is
known in the original language as
Djibouti in this particular instance
Chad Boseman was quite aware of 18
Egyptian history and he chose to play
this role so that the position of Toth
could be accurately depicted by a person
of African ancestry I appreciate the
fact that Chad wanted to add a sense of
historical accuracy to this particular
character if I was to rate this film The
Gods of Egypt I would give it a zero if
I were to rate the scenes with Chad with
Bozeman I would say give it a five it
contains truth but it is not true
cold the dark lining around the eyes
women wore it and Men wore it that was
used primarily as protection from the
intense sunlight it's the same thing
that you see on the football field or a
baseball field where the athlete would
put black underneath their eye to absorb
the intense rays of sunlight so that
they could see clearly
in the name of the Senate and the people
of Rome
and by their will
their representations of the clothing
the hairdressers is pretty accurate
based on the physical evidence that was
left the two staffs that we see
Cleopatra holding the crook and the
flail the crook is the shepherd's Crook
and it indicates that the king the ruler
is a Shepherd to the people of their
country the flail is an interest is an
instrument that is similar to a fly
swatter and it's used to swat away
distractions enemies of Egypt if you
combine these two instruments then what
they represent is the king or Queen's
ability to protect the people of the
land and to do away with the enemies of
the land who would bring danger and
threats to the territory
there cannot be enough hours in the days
of a queen again the use of white
actresses to depict Cleopatra is taking
liberties with historical truths based
on the archaeological evidence that has
been found of Cleopatra's sisters
another family members she was probably
closer to Halle Berry than Elizabeth
Taylor
[Music]
now it's also very little evidence to
indicate how Cleopatra died so the idea
of her holding an asp to her breast and
abiding her is fiction there is no
evidence to validate that is how
Cleopatra died I give it a seven my
favorite of the clips that we've seen is
Raiders of the Lost Ark The Narrative
was fictitional but the presentation of
the artifacts was as real as can be if
you enjoyed this video click the link
for more exciting information